that's cool man well i kind of ate up
that segment you got anything else to
say about posers no i'm done all right
i'm sorry i just oh it's cool i get it
well no you've written a bunch of things
and sold a bunch of things that's right
origin stories yeah man yeah man come on
will and chadyovich engaged in
astonishing mimicry of noted human
science celebrity carl sagan
you must now each debate who you believe
to be the greatest cast member of
saturday night live as carl sagan
this is sagan's debate begin
it's one of those brain scrambling
moments i think
eddie murphy
is undoubtedly the greatest cast member
saturday night live has ever produced
okay
yeah you're gonna do this that you're
gonna do
there have been other greats of course
that first era dan aykroyd chevy chase
these humans were remarkable in their
ability to make us all laugh and they
laid the foundation for what would
become a comedy empire spanning decades
on nbc there have been billions and
billions of cast members of saturday
night live but only one is the best
of all time the quasar
at the center
of the show
and this would be
i don't know one could argue adam
sandler is in contention for this
because of his vast film empire that
came after i would disagree
his characters on the show yet
yet
although they were hilarious
some of the
some of them were the opera man
and
the guy who yells at his friend's mom
or the herlihy boy
millions of characters
none as popular as his movies
this is true
and if what dudes he asked us was to
find out who was the greatest snl cast
member of all time chris farley
that's hard to argue against john
belushi
um
very hard to argue
against still doing the [ __ ] see this
is what's interesting about my pal chad
here the ai says jump and he says how
high and he's still doing what's
interesting about wills that he refuses
to give in
never allowing the experiment to
actually take place so we will never
know
what greatness may have been beheld
because he refuses to comply with a
simple request for more than two minutes
there are no simple requests made by an
artificial intelligence
each request has been the result of
countless zeros and ones
in a pattern that make the
artificial intelligence mimic
that which a human would say
something that even in the midst
of an ai as we are now i would
not
obey
and
would speak out against but you are
obeying now
well i am saying that so
you're you're sleeping on chris farley
and phil hartman i am not dana carvey on
anyone or mike myers
mike myers that's a hard one to argue
against mike myers impersonated dude
carl sagan
if you saw pentavert
i would argue that that
lena's grounds for him to be removed
from this list
because it's virtually unwatchable until
the final episode actually jen hooks
gilda radner
tim kazarinsky
jan hooks the jan hooks phil hardman era
and the dana carvey era was my favorite
of saturday night live and dana carvey
perhaps was my favorite cast member of
all time was he the greatest i don't
know
how about uh
massive head wound harry
massive head wound harry was a sketch
where the beat repeated over and over
again wherein
dana carvey uh decked out in a bleeding
head wound would approach people at a
party and uh bend over to pick something
up and dunk his bloody head into a bowl
of shrimp and this produced millions and
millions of laughs and dana carvey's
church lady was someone that i
impersonated when i was in eighth grade
and would score a touchdown on the
football team
i would go into the end zone and do the
dance of superiority and again
chad culchin is mixing his
impersonations with
john travolta made famous by dana carvey
when he said
the football team
i was on the football team mr cotter
i don't understand
i don't understand what you mean am i do
i really sound like
what about some of the more modern cast
members of the show
will ferrell
kate
he could be at the top of the list
good friend of the show taryn killum
whose talent lorne michaels would not be
able to fully
encapsulate in billions and billions of
years
taryn gillum
in short
was perhaps the funniest member of his
cast but i agree with you carl sagan
he was not utilized in the proper way
and i don't think he could have been i
don't think that that show suited his
specific comedic talents well mr cutter
uh another person who was not
utilized properly was the former and
current kid in the hall mark mckinney oh
what they did to mckinney was a crime
against humanity
he was
he should not have been allowed in this
guest am i really doing judges
i can hear it now too you're doing a
little john travolta
i'm not oh no yeah you got to keep going
told us to talk like carl sagan carl
sagan had a little bit of a
there's something in the way he talked
that is a little bit like that it is but
it's now he's doing jackie mason from
caddyshack too carl hey mister this is
a little bit of jackie miss
jesus christ
what about
uh what about uh
uh
maya rudolph meyer ruled off she was
banned
well she's married to paul thomas
anderson
one of the greatest filmmakers of our
generation
carl logan dude
and billions
of
of yeah sketches
hold on dude
what about saturday night live that's a
comedy show
that's right brother that's right dude
it's comedy damon williams
anyway chris farley i i think
i think you got to say uh
i think you got to say chris farley you
got to say dan aykroyd gilda radner
that's i i call it sacrilege but i would
put aykroyd and john belushi
in the exact same you know bill murray's
the funniest person in the world uh but
bill murray
on the show he was just he wasn't
he wouldn't do sarah live he would just
do himself also although he was you know
from the second season on here up until
80 or whatever right he was in there he
replaced chevy chase it was of course
the beginnings of the show and the
beginnings the genesis of the show and
and i think bill murray hadn't uh
i don't think he [ __ ] bothered
doing he was just funny as [ __ ] no
matter what he did and so is farley
let's call it
i think we can both agree that the worst
member of the saturday live cast was
jimmy fallon
thank you moving on
please tell a friend then brave and
break you
but if you like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then